are there musicians you guys go to to
talk about actually playing like are
there mentors that you guys have i think
when we were starting out and playing
shows with other people festivals
especially were always so exciting to me
because you get a chance to see
like eight other drummers and i was i
was not a
particularly proficient drummer but i i
just especially in the early days i
remember just
literally watching watching everyone
watching how they had their feet on the
drum pedals watching how they held their
sticks what kind of drums they were
using just trying to soak it up because
i think i i wasn't really sure what i
was doing so i think that was a great
education and then sometimes it's you
get the chance to meet some people who
are in a kind of similar position like
occasionally i've had the good fortune
to have a nice conversation with larry
mullen from u2 and that's always an
interesting perspective because
obviously his band is they're so huge
and it was a really
useful just such a you know he was very
kind and very generous with his
thoughts and advice and so that kind of
stuff is really so it's invaluable we
had some amazing advice from people
along the way you know um early on it
was like ian mcculloch from uh echo and
the bunny man he would come in the
studio a lot and
tell us what kinds of songs we need to
do
and i remember i remember um after we we
supported you too in uh in ireland
in uh i must have been like 2000 or
something and
bono invited will and i ran to his house
the next day and he was telling us what
to do as well
he's very generous he was so lovely
generous with his advice absolutely
we just sort of kids straight out of
college and we're suddenly in bono's
house in
woody harrelson
but he said he jumped he told you you
said how do we get there he said just
get in a cab and ask for bono's house
yeah yeah so we just got in the first
cab we found he said take us to bono's
house he's like yeah sure no problem
don't pay enough
just right like that everyone knows
everyone knows
how generous would bonolo to like
actually give you guys advice i mean was
it good advice i mean
or do you just kind of like do your own
thing yeah you told us to stop
good advice
get out